but I just need to warn you when I do
things I go all in my friendship with
Niko's on the line now what I love about
this shot is that you can't really tell
that I'm holding a camera you might have
even thought that this was a drone shot
whereas in reality this is just simply a
360 camera called the insta 360 one and
it's just on a little selfie stick what
this allows you to get are some really
interesting and unique angles because
you can stabilize the image and do crazy
stuff like this whoa whoa whoa it's
pretty sweet right now the other day we
were shooting an archery challenge on
one wheels and at the end of the whole
shoot on a whim I decided to put this on
a bow and I just fired the entire camera
selfie stick and off right up into the
air and accidentally got one of coolest
shots I'd ever seen before and I
instantly knew I've got to do more of
this and I got to take this to the next
level I got to get the most extreme
shots I can so in today's video we're
gonna kick this out and make this a
proper 360 camera on an arrow see how
insane of a shot that we can get let's
get to it
now you might be wondering how exactly
does this work why can't the camera see
the stick you might be asking yourself
did I paint the stick out how did I
remove it in post turns out the answer
is so much simpler than that because I
didn't do any work the camera just
literally can't see this because it's in
the blind spot of the camera and this
stick is just perfectly in the center of
that am I born you're mine right now Sam
here's the cool 360 arrow shot is an
arrow that flies across the whole world
and it goes like this into somes mouth
now the problem I can already see is the
fact that I'm gonna be placing this
camera in severe danger because we have
to catch it and if we don't it will
break I know it will break because we've
done it before no so there's a couple
mods that I actually want to make to
this whole rig here to help make it
easier to shoot and also safer for the
cameras life so this is the very first
instance Reece exceed one camera that we
got here I was writing my 1 wheel when
it gave out on me and so I ended up
breaking the insta 360 camera as you can
see here here specifically was the
design problem it's a plastic quarter
inch screw mount here and when it hit a
tree this thing just busted off right
here this is a stress concentration
right here this braking here probably
actually saved the rest of the camera
because this just broke off and that
acted as a bit of like a airbag so I'm
gonna try to actually design some little
part here to act as an in-between for
the stick and the camera so that if it
does fall that mount itself will break
before the camera so ideally I can just
print another mount to replace it that
camera still continues to work and we're
still able to pop off shots now the
second bit is actually less for peace of
mind and more for actual functionality
because this is just a wide flat spot
here and the string kept slipping around
it you know like
this so I'm gonna also try to design
just a little 3d printed not that the
string can sit in and won't go off the
sides final print is done I'm going to
try to remove this last piece here now
let's see if this actually worked I
think it's a pretend it did it fit
perfectly check that out the idea is
that this will go right onto the camera
and then this will slip right in there
so let's test that that I mean is broken
that worked perfectly it broke exactly
where I thought it would and it didn't
take that much force that's I couldn't
have hoped for a better solution so we
all know that good things come in sets
of three Lord of the Rings movies
strikes in baseball and give contest
today we are announcing the third annual
corridor crew gift contest you like that
intro yeah that's right it's just
started okay the rules are real easy
pick a sweet moment a sweet shot
something that you think would make a
cool gift get fit and then send it to
gifts at corridor digital comm this year
it's going to be slightly slightly
different in that we can only have one
submission per person in the last you'll
you're able to submit as many gifts as
you want the reason for that is because
some of you guys just sent like a lot of
low effort gifts here at corridor we are
all about high effort art or high effort
shitposts the gif doesn't have to be
from our stuff it just needs to be
corridor related so you can put our face
into something else if you want or
whatever generally speaking in these
feet corridor okay just like I think you
guys would like this clip from an action
movie it's like no no no remember that
name is a little bike gift I was a heck
of a gift the one
that one last year was the invisible
bike and that was like now it's high
after right there
that's why effort so submit your gifts
to gifts at corridor digital comm one
gift per person please and with the
winner will get what does the winner get
Christian core digital t-shirt brand new
secret merch whoa do we have like a bad
gift or two this is the bad new Ford
gets this towel look forward to seeing
the gift from you guys and look forward
to seeing those tips from you guys can't
wait to see them
can't wait looking forward today looking
for this thing this gets me guys looking
for can't wait to see those gifts from
you guys keep them keep them up I'll do
nothing that you guys are doing inside a
dream about a week ago that Sam broke my
bow tripod and Sam's going up the film
with you guys and you're gonna use my
bow so they should let him drive her as
much as possible
Niko really cares about his bows so he
lends it we must receive the tutorial
this belonged to my deceased uncle it's
got sentimental value also not gonna lie
like it's also one of the most stable
bows that shot so here we are at the
park it's time to test the thing now you
might be wondering why don't I have
feathers here well this thing has enough
balance mass that I don't think we even
need it
oh yeah speaking of which if you have
this contraption you can do this to buy
3d printing the pieces that I've made a
link in the description so you can
download these where I'm thinking on
Thingiverse yeah it's a whole universe
of things is there any special procedure
to this I mean not really and I say we
just start small and work our way up
okay you guys ready test number one
[Music]
ready I'm gonna go straight up but it's
gonna go that way
[Music]
second tests already broken it it's
rural doing it but it's the camera still
rolling look at this green it was the
pressure it like that was something I
actually worried about cool so we
learned something very important from
that and that was just the simple act of
catching it still introduced enough
shock to break this thing so I'm gonna
try to remedy that by just putting a
little bit more gaff tape around it okay
an easy way to help make this go a
little bit more powerful is to put a
second string on it maybe it won't do
much but maybe a little maybe it'll add
something so I'm just gonna put a second
string on I don't think you're ever
supposed to actually do this I promise I
won't break it this time the way to do
that then is to catch it with as much
like gotta catch it like an egg yeah be
like cheese I just want to see that bow
shatter and rinse
here goes the test check out the shop
from an era camera broke again the same
exact thing happened dang I wonder if
that means I just gotta make that piece
stronger problem is that design a little
thicker you want to shoot it yeah I'd
love to shoot it I just need to warn you
when I do things I go all in you're
gonna pull it back all the way so I'm
going to shoot it over this tree here
I'm gonna shoot it over the street and
it's just gonna keep going you know what
Sam I hope you're right so then we can
do the bigger tree we're gonna see how
big we can go and then go bigger all
right here we go all the way never hold
back I'm just worried that I'm gonna
pull it back I'm just gonna like get
clipped on something and won't fly all
the way but we'll see all right here we
go I'm aiming for Jake
[Music]
[Applause]
alright that was 99% still rolling
though cameras still rolling
I think snapped like a toothpick son I
here's the thing I have to admit I want
75% blast not full blast I was like
pulling back more and more and more and
more and more and I started to get into
a point I was like if I pull too hard
my friendship with Niko's on the line
Jake I need you so you need me to stand
on the edge and then take the final leap
I'm going to shoot it competently in a
manner that I think will result in the
best possible shot what did my
friendships on the line alright this is
our last piece if this breaks this is
our last shot today it's not gonna break
I don't know if Niko's bow is gonna
survive this but you're gonna go to 100%
right
I refuse from answering that question
Dovie is with us and I hope that this
goes well
I'm gonna go full ham this time you're
supposed to do that this time I didn't
know dude I didn't want to break Niko's
bow and have him hate me forever all
right ready
[Music]
[Applause]
good I always kill a bird
let's go again oh man that is this
thing's still rolling I'm gonna try
shooting it over that tree right there
I'm just gonna try to shoot this thing
as hard as I can I'm going straight
through light a little gap in the tree
here alright here goes nothing oh no the
very climb level it that went a hundred
percent on you and 99 I walked that's so
high
why don't we just wiggle the tree and
see if it falls no climb up a little bit
this is the real fun in the video this
is the real content teamwork
a theme of content creators of No
Boundaries hi my name is Sam Gorski
co-founder of quarter digital and we're
a team of content creators with no
boundaries you easily could have just
said your own name there and stick hit
the lens
you shouldn't go higher it starts to
like be legit dangerous no you're doing
a great job shaking it no no no no
you're you're wiggling is working we
could give him nico's bow looks like
you're about ten feet from its tell Neko
stuff gonna see you back down here nice
and safe at the end of this
rich J subscribe
don't worry we're here to catch you just
watch out for these concrete pillars hey
man I can't believe this
what's your head's boys drop one piece
oh well that bonus points it's been an
interesting day the camera was still
blue there's some hardcore scratches on
this did you stop the camera no no no no
silencing no that's redacted redacted no
that's that's from us us and by us Sam
how dare you exempt yourself from
culpability here nothing happens in my
hands what you do it's just it busted up
the wood a little bit right here when
the heavy back end of the wait you broke
nicos bow I did not break his bow scale
from 1 to broken it's like a three no in
hindsight what we should have done was
wrap each of these little notches into a
bit of gaff tape to help smooth it out
cuz I think this is actually what cut
and damaged the boat these little
notches here I mean he's not gonna be
happy about that
no he's not he's not gonna be happy
about that how do we make him happy
about it we all admit that we got a
great shot in the process
so Neko some good news I think we got
some pretty sweet shots yeah but I think
the camera did that to to the bow was
that that like that before that that bit
of no this wasn't all shoot up like that
and splintered okay I think we can fix
it if we Dunkle's botanist if I'm saying
the work that if we just put some
lacquer on it I think it will all just
kind of like nicely crease back into
there okay all right yeah
I hope you can fix it yeah I do too we
were using caution and care it's not
like we just were like slinging arrows
out of there like without paying
attention to that I think it was just
with the way that the collapsible part
yeah I like the collapsible parts
I think ran along there and then chewed
it so yeah we'll get some lacquer and
see if we can fix it so that happened I
always feel kind of bad when we like
break our friends and stuff especially
really nice bows from dead uncle's so
sorry Nico I feel bad I was really happy
with the results that we were getting so
I went ahead and actually went back out
we ended up getting another idea what if
we actually put the arrow with the
camera and fired both of those things at
the same time you can actually see the
arrow flying through the air from the
arrows perspective but you know what
from my chit chat we have a whole
montage of all those sweet shots we got
throughout this whole video now
[Music]
you know I got it coming up probably
good grammar intact the camera seems to
be working just fine no scratches ooh
yeah no scratches on the lenses
I think the arrow was placed just fine I
think we should be able to see that